reforma de pensiones más apoyo para
Ucrania e Independencia energética estas
fueron algunas de las metas que se
planteó para 2023 el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron en su discurso de fin de
año el mandatario galo afirmó que la
Guerra de Ucrania sigue siendo uno de
los principales retos para el próximo
año
en el último día del año Rusia lanzó al
menos 20 misiles contra Ucrania de los
cuales el ejército local asegura haber
derribado más de la mitad se debe
registraron explosiones en kiev y su
cercanías que hasta el momento dejan un
muerto por lo de selenski arremetió
contra Vladimir Putin tildando lo de
terrorista
personalidades del mundo despiden al
Papa emérito Benedicto 16 Quien murió
hoy a sus 95 años El Vaticano señaló su
avanzada edad Como la causa de su muerte
el cuerpo del pontífice retirado ya será
en la Basílica de San Pedro desde el
próximo lunes y su funeral será el
jueves
Bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa de este final de año en 2023
en 2022 les habla Daniela Blandón
comenzamos en Francia el presidente de
Manuel macron se dirigió a sus
compatriotas desde el palacio del hélice
o para pronunciar su discurso de fin de
año entre las metas que se planteó el
mandatario galo está una profunda
reforma institucional así como el
impulso de su polémica reforma pensional
que pretende Elevar progresivamente la
edad de jubilación a 65 años desde los
62 actuales
el objetivo es consolidar nuestro
régimen de pensiones por repartición sin
esta reforma se vería amenazado porque
seguimos financiando a crédito para esto
el alargamiento de nuestras carreras de
trabajo Se hará progresivamente a lo
largo de diez años y también teniendo en
cuenta las carreras largas las carreras
fragmentadas teniendo en cuenta las
diferentes características de los
diferentes y esto nos permitirá
equilibrar la financiación de nuestras
pensiones en nuestros países donde se
vive más tiempo y además de la Reforma
de pensiones el presidente macron
prometió seguir apoyando a Ucrania en su
defensa de la invasión rusa que según él
ha traído enormes consecuencias como la
crisis energética y también la
alimentaria En ese sentido el jefe de
estado francés afirmó que la defensa de
Ucrania ante el ataque de Moscú sigue
siendo uno de los principales retos para
el 2023
quiero decirles a nuestros amigos
ucranianos los respetamos y los
admiramos su combate por la defensa de
su nación es Heroico y nos inspira a
todos
y durante el próximo año
sin falta estaremos a su lado los
acompañaremos los ayudaremos hasta la
victoria y estaremos juntos para
construir una paz justa y duradera
cuenten con Francia y cuenten con Europa
y precisamente sobre la Guerra de
Ucrania en el último día de 2022 Rusia y
Ucrania dijeron haber liberado a 222
soldados en el más reciente intercambio
de prisioneros en el marco de la Guerra
sin embargo los ataques rusos en Ucrania
no cesaron varias ciudades del país
incluida la capital kiev cayeron misiles
rusos que dejaron Al menos un muerto y
daños materiales Mientras tanto en Rusia
el presidente Vladimir Putin brindó con
militares para celebrar el año nuevo
Samuel Salgado nos amplía
las alarmas antiaéreas no dejaron de
sonar en Ucrania en víspera de año nuevo
en kiev una oleada de misiles rusos dejó
al menos un muerto y daños materiales en
zonas residenciales interrumpiendo los
tímidos festejos para despedir el año de
la invasión mi esposo y yo literalmente
fuimos arrojados al pasillo recuperamos
la conciencia en el pasillo escuchamos
cristales rompiéndose y luego hubo una
explosión una tras otra la capital no
fue la única ciudad blanco de la
veintena de misiles rusos de los cuales
las fuerzas ucranianas aseguraron haber
derribado 12 en las sureñas Nicolás y
saporilla varias explosiones dejaron
heridos y afectaron edificios Ucrania
denuncia que estos ataques iban
dirigidos contra civiles
llevaron a cabo tales ataques en semana
santa en navidad en año nuevo se llaman
a sí mismos cristianos están muy
orgullosos de su ortodoxia pero están
siguiendo al
cerca de la frontera ucraniana en el
lado ruso el presidente Vladimir Putin
se reunió en la base militar de rostov
del Don y brindó con militares para
celebrar el año nuevo
Rusia ha sido empujada a esa línea o
regala todo o pelea pero mientras haya
personas como ustedes hombres y mujeres
que estén a su lado por supuesto no
podemos regalar nada debemos luchar
debemos seguir adelante
también condecoró al general sergeiking
jefe de la operación militar en Ucrania
más temprano en Moscú el ministro de
defensa de Rusia dio un mensaje de año
nuevo triunfalista
nuestra Victoria como el año nuevo es
inevitable
culmina el medio de bombardeos el año
más difícil para Ucrania y sin
posibilidades de paz a la vista el 2023
llegará con nuevas sanciones económicas
de Estados Unidos a Rusia y millonarias
ayudas militares de Washington a kiev
y en otras noticias del día líderes
mundiales lamentan el fallecimiento del
Papa emérito Benedicto 16 hoy a sus 95
años la capilla ardiente para que se
despidan los seguidores será el lunes 2
de enero y se extenderá hasta el
miércoles cuatro en la Basílica de San
Pedro y el entierro se realizará el
jueves Ramiro cuevar berena tiene los
detalles
Benedicto 16 ha muerto este sábado en la
mañana del Vaticano la noticia fue
confirmada por la entidad católica que
lo despidió con campanadas
con conmoción recordemos la suave
persona José inmóviles con emoción
recordamos su persona tan noble tan
bondadosa sentimos en nuestro corazón
tal gratitud gratitud a Dios por
habérselo regalado la iglesia y al mundo
gratitud a él por todo el bien que hizo
y especialmente por su testimonio de fe
y oración especialmente en estos últimos
años de su vida retirada
los líderes del mundo lamentaron el
fallecimiento del pontífice el canciller
Alemán Olaf shots despidió a su
compatriota el primero en llegar al alto
mando de la santa sede
como un Papa alemán Benedicto 16 fue
para muchos no sólo en este país un
líder especial de la iglesia el mundo
pierde a una figura formadora de la
Iglesia Católica una personalidad
controvertida Y a un teólogo hábil mis
pensamientos están con el Papa Francisco
por su parte el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron se pronunció en
Solidaridad con los creyentes
mi pensamiento está con los católicos de
Francia y de todo el mundo afligidos por
la partida de su santidad Benedicto XVI
que trabajó con Alma e inteligencia por
un mundo más fraterno
de este lado del mundo el mandatario
entrante de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva recordó su encuentro con Benedicto
en la visita que el pontífice hizo en
2007 y deseo consuelo a los fieles del
líder católico
la capilla ardiente del Papa emérito se
hará desde el lunes hasta el miércoles
en la Basílica de San Pedro para que los
creyentes puedan dar su último adiós el
entierro será presido por su sucesor el
Papa Francisco el jueves 5 de enero
el gobierno ecuatoriano anunció la
detención del ex policía Germán Cáceres
en Colombia él es el principal
sospechoso del feminicidio de su esposa
María Belén Bernal en septiembre el
feminicidio de Bernal se convirtió en un
símbolo de la lucha contra la violencia
de género en Ecuador que sólo en 2022
dejó casi 300 víctimas
103 días tres meses después del
feminicidio de María Belén Bernal la
policía colombiana detuvo en una playa
de la costa caribeña el principal
sospechoso Germán Cáceres sus marido la
madre María Belén agradeció a los
uniformados colombianos y señaló en
medios locales su preocupación ante la
posibilidad de que Cáceres se suicide
durante su traslado demostrando una vez
más que los familiares de la víctima no
confían en la institucionalidad
ecuatoriana
recordemos que el presidente sacó al
ministro de ese momento y Carrillo
afirmó que la Policía Nacional y su
espíritu de cuerpo para no Investigar de
la forma correcta del asesinato de María
Belén el cuerpo sin vida de María Belén
fue hallado el 21 de Septiembre tras
pasar 10 días desaparecida después de
haber sido vista por última vez en la
escuela superior de policía donde
trabajaba Cáceres sus marido denunció la
desaparición fue retenido por unas horas
para ser liberado Poco después la
autopsia determinó que murió por
estrangulamiento y asfixia para entonces
Cáceres ya estaba prófugo de la justicia
y buscado por la Interpol incluso la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos del Estado ecuatoriano
investigar el feminicidio y los
familiares de María Belén iniciaban su
lucha en una búsqueda de Justicia
calificando el hecho como un crimen de
estado este sábado la fiscalía de
Ecuador señaló que una Delegación se
encuentra en el país vecino para
coordinar el traslado a Quito de Cáceres
Germán Cáceres buscado por el
feminicidio de María Belén Bernal ha
sido localizado y capturado mi
reconocimiento al trabajo conjunto entre
la policía de Ecuador fiscalía Ecuador y
la fiscalía colombiana una vez en el
país recibirá todo el peso de la ley el
caso de María Belén es uno más en
Ecuador donde el feminicidio está dentro
del Código Penal desde 2014 y que solo
en 2022 según datos oficiales hubo casi
300 feminicidios unas cifras que para
los organismos feministas independientes
esconden un gran subregistro así
llegamos al final de las noticias feliz
día para todos
[Música]